paléo est finie
les élèves de cette classe du collège
saint-augustin ont choisi de suivre une
option comédie musicale objectif
présenter oliver twist dans un théâtre
une idée d'eleanor là-bas professeur
principal de la classe
le projet s'articule autour de deux axes
être acteur et être spectateur les
élèves des ateliers pour essayer de
progresser et de pouvoir monter leur
spectacle et à côté de ça normalement
ils ont je dis bien normalement parce qu
elles étant donné le contexte sanitaire
c'est un peu compliqué mais normalement
ils ont la possibilité d'aller voir des
comédies musicales des spectacles
la dynamique de l'option se retrouve au
sein de l'ensemble des cours en français
on étudie les aventures de l'hiver twist
de charles dickens en éducation musicale
les élèves travaillent autour de la
comédie musicale en arts plastiques qui
vont travailler sur le décor du
spectacle en eps y travaille
particulièrement la danse une discipline
triple qui englobe aussi bien le chant
la danse et le théâtre pour travailler
le spectacle de fin d'année un
professionnel intervient dans le cadre
d'ateliers hebdomadaires et bien tous
les vendredis en ce moment donné des
ateliers donc de deux heures pour
essayer de mettre en place cette comédie
musicale c'est un projet assez ambitieux
avec des enfants qui pour beaucoup n'ont
pas fait de comédie musicale qui est
l'art qui mélange les trois disciplines
théâtre chant danse mais je suis tombé
sur des élèves très motivés
au total trente deux élèves ont choisi
de participer à ce projet ils ont été
sélectionnés sur motivation en 5e on
avait une option arts vivants et ça
s'était bien passé du coup j'ai voulu
continuer en quatrième comme c'est
vraiment un projet commun à la classe on
peut même révisé pendant
le repas est tous enfin c'est bien parce
qu'on est un peu tous solidaires on se
connaît on se contrôle tous les jours
donc bah en fait c'est aussi beaucoup
ensemble qu'on fait les artistes en
herbe se prépare à présenter la comédie
musicale oliver twist le mardi 8 juin
2021 au théâtre alexandre dumas